jetzt erreichen uns die nächste
horrormeldungen aus der antarktis nasa
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
haben mehrere risse entdeckt die sich
durch das so genannte grund schelfeis
arbeiten fest steht wenn sich die beiden
entscheidenden größe erreichen bricht
ein gigantischer eisberg ab das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
es handelt sich um eine eismasse mit
einer fläche von 1700 quadratkilometern
also fast doppelt so groß wie berlin und
insgesamt hat die antarktis inzwischen
eine unfassbare menge eis verloren 26
kinder gibt's täglich faszinieren die
wissenschaft videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen die prozesse in der antarktis
werden auch für uns in europa und das
nicht nur an den küsten ziemlich
unangenehme folgen haben studien zufolge
würde der globale meeresspiegel im worst
case nämlich dann wenn das gesamte
arktis eis schmelzen würde um
unglaubliche 58 meter ansteigen eine
absolute katastrophe und eben nicht nur
für die küstengebiete dieser erde bisher
ging man davon aus dass vor allem der
westen des kontinents vom abschmelzen
betroffen ist anfang des jahres 2009 10
haben wir ja hier bei pixum science
fiction über einen riesigen und äußerst
mysteriösen hohlraum im sogenannten
zweites gletscher berichtet ein zehn
kilometer langer und 350 meter hohen
raum der wohl ursprünglich mal mit 14
milliarden tonnen eis gefüllt war
alleine das abschmelzen des zweite
skechers könnte den weltweit
meeresspiegel um sage und schreibe 65
zentimeter annehmen verschiedene
forschungsteams haben in der jüngeren
zeit aber immer wieder gezeigt dass auch
die ostantarktis wohl deutlich mehr
eisfeld als man bislang dachte und auch
das so genannte grund schelfeis um das
es beim aktuellen alarm der nasa geht
liegt im östlichen bereich
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler berichten nämlich jetzt
von rissen in den eismassen die dazu
führen könnten dass ein gewaltiger
eisberg ins östliche mittelmeer treibt
das zeigen aktuelle satelliten aufnahmen
für beunruhigung sorgt vor allem ein
neuer riss mit dem namen dass man einst
der bislang als stabil galt doch im jahr
2012 begann er zu wachsen und zwar in
nördliche richtung pro jahr wächst
chance mainz gerade um ganze 4 km
im jahr das problem dabei somit ist er
nur noch wenige kilometer vom
sogenannten halloween riss entfernt der
vor zweieinhalb jahren um halloween
entdeckt wurde und sich in östlicher
richtung verlängert klar ist wenn sich
den beiden risse des grund schelfeises
erreichen spaltet sich ein gigantisches
stück eis ab die kanten des schelfeises
hatten sich den beobachtungen zufolge
seit 1915 in nur geringer
geschwindigkeit verändert dabei ist das
so genannte kalben also das abspalten
der eisberge vom schelfeis laut
fachleuten ein durchaus normaler vorgang
doch die veränderung und eisverluste in
der antarktis haben laut nasa in den
vergangenen jahren rasant an
geschwindigkeit zugelegt und das ist
eine wirklich alarmierende erkenntnisse
vor zwei jahren brach der eisberg 68 an
der antarktischen halbinsel ab mit sage
und schreibe fünf 1800 quadratkilometern
ein wirklich gigantischer brocken und
fast siebenmal so groß wie berlin die
region hatte sich vorher erwärmt und
forschungsteams hatten schmelzwasser
tümpel beobachtet diese hatten die den
abbruch damals wohl beschleunigt
bezüglich der aktuellen veränderungen in
der ostantarktis ist noch nicht wirklich
viel mit eindeutiger sicherheit zu sagen
fest steht derzeit nur sobald sich die
beiden risse im grund schelfeis
erreichen entsteht ein eisberg mit einer
fläche von etwa 1700 quadratkilometern
und damit eben knapp doppelt so groß wie
berlin doch wann genau das passiert
können die nasa experten und expertinnen
derzeit noch nicht voraussagen
mehrere faktoren wie etwa sturmwellen
und die bewegung des umgebenden meeres
spielen eine rolle und könnten die sache
beschleunigen sicherheitshalber wurde
deswegen jedenfalls die britische
forschungsstation in der nähe
geschlossen die besatzung der heli 6 hat
die mobile station von kurzer zeit
verlassen dabei gab es schon vor zwei
jahren einen umzug auf die angeblich
sichere seite des risses die fachleute
können das ganze nur auf sich zukommen
lassen ausgeschlossen ist auch nicht
dass der antarktische winter das
schelfeis auch noch einmal eine zeit
lang stabilisieren kann
doch welche gründe gibt es für die risse
auch darauf gibt es keine eindeutigen
antworten denn die details solcher
prozesse sind tatsächlich noch
weitestgehend
unbekannt handelt es sich vielleicht
doch um ein natürliches ereignis oder
bedeutet alles dass die ostantarktis die
bislang als relativ stabil galt in
bewegung gerät das es dort lange nicht
mehr so gut aussieht wie in der
vergangenheit hatte vor allem eine
studie aus dem vergangenen jahr
verdeutlicht insgesamt 44 internationale
organisationen hatten sich
zusammengeschlossen um den eisverlust in
der antarktis zu kalkulieren bis zum
jahr 2012 hat es demnach durch massiven
schneefall eine zunahme der eismasse in
dieser region gegeben
doch auch das ist jetzt geschichte denn
laut der studie von 2018 gab es in den
fünf jahren von 2012 bis 2017
allein in dieser region einen jährlichen
verlust von achtung 28 milliarden tonnen
eis das muss man sich mal vorstellen
dass als schild der antarktis hat
demnach also seit 1992 insgesamt etwa
drei billionen tonnen eis verloren mit
dieser menge könnte man ganz deutschland
rund acht meter hoch mit wasser bedecken
eine unvorstellbare menge also noch eben
nicht nur die reine wassermenge
alarmiert die fachwelt sondern eben auch
die geschwindigkeit 40 prozent des
verlustes passierten der studie zufolge
in den vergangenen fünf jahren hat ja
eine ganz spezielle eigenschaft die ist
etwas unberechenbar macht die dichte
anomalie des wassers das video anklicken
also hier anschauen und natürlich bei
kings abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran